yes chairman I'm just check the streams
going
yeah we're live chairman thank you very
much good afternoon and welcome to this
council meeting on Tuesday the 23rd of
June 2020
my name is councillor Bob boyce and I am
the chairman of the Morden District
Council this meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect on
the 4th of April in response to the coab
819 situation there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
including our new working practices
which have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the etiquette for this
meeting first of all please could I ask
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone remains muted and
your video feed off we're not addressing
the committee this will reduce
background noise and avoid any in
unintentional disturbances this meeting
will be hosted remotely via conference
software which allows members of the
public to virtually attend the meeting
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others and observe the government's
lockdown measures we might encounter
some glitches it's afternoon so I hope
that everyone will bear with us as we
get used to this new way of working we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in the
meeting you are given your consent of
being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak I will then invite you
at the appropriate time members are
reminded that apart from indicating you
wish to speak or that you have to leave
the meeting your chat function should
not be used for any other purpose
members the process this afternoon will
obviously be different and for some
items are may invite each member to
speak in turn therefore I would
encourage all members to keep your
contribution as clear and concise as
possible please when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers believe
that ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number but I also ensure that
everyone is directly connected
to a power supply so that nobody drops
out due to battery life shortage and
Loused if members need to leave the
meeting at any point please do make this
known and use the chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting now if I may ask officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves starting moved Richard Holmes
so grab the members Richard Holmes truck
to a service delivery site Simon Quelch
and one of the lawyers here they're
already getting a lot of interference
Tara Tara sorry chairman Tara parity
services officer thank you and I think
we've got two other officers present
please show yourselves tin house and
specialist conservation in heritage I'm
Gavin Kings North I'm a planning lead
for the development consent alder for
Brad will be and communications manager
members members somebody has got some
background noise would you please mute
your microphone I think you'll find it's
not mailing me up Scotty oh that's
probably a previous existence this is
very disruptive please stop that noise
and now taro can you carry out a roll
call of members in attendance please
switch your microphone on and confirm
that you're in attendance please I'm
starting me counselor Bamford please
yes I'm present Thank You councillor
Basinger
yes I'm president cancer miss be present
thank you I casted Brian Beal it's
labelled yeah Channel
yes Tara I'm here thank you at the
moment
Katsuji yes eat cats the Dharan
president councillor Edwards yes present
mrs. Fleming president that's a frico
resin thank you cats the hakka risen he
counts the head president al Rosen Oh
somehow yes yeah president counselor
Jarvis present thank you that's the keys
cancer second hey Donna
Thank You counselor maze cancer maze she
she was present earlier tarus yeah might
I look I'll just check see if mr. Jenner
[Music]
counselor Morley counsel Morris go up
and earn and welcome Thank You counselor
done present a shorter see isn't Tara
thank you that's the Siddal present
answer Skeens
yep here thank you cancer stamp
president tara present Swain president
cancel mrs. Thompson I'm present Cara
thank you I can't sir miss white I'm
sorry
thank you fine if I'm a counselor
fearless experiencing logon problems and
he is expected to join us very shortly
Thank You counselor heard thank you
sorry Tom Thompson here counselor keys
ditto is having trouble locking on I put
his number on the chat in hopes that
someone can help them thank you sorry to
interrupt
oh thank you counselor Thompson right
Tara I think we can go now
- apologies for absence have you any
I've got no policies chairman um thank
you thank you
and now go to agenda item three
declaration
of interests to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable peculiar
interest other pecuniary interest or
non-pecuniary relating to items of
business on the agenda how can I go out
to board here bad councilor voice role
of the council that we break in well
first of all the fact that you're
chairing this meeting is a bit of a
question mark for me but given that
you're two of the items are about the
joint standards committee and you
clearly have a direct interest so I
assume you will be declaring your
interest but then that makes me wonder
why on earth you are I don't think
that's a point of interest oh I think
it's a point of interest and it's a
point of order that you're chairing the
meeting any of the people named in this
report
Akane's councillor schemes sorry I'm
finished what I'm saying
how all the people listed in that in
that report criticised in that report
have PR here and they're going to vote
on something that they clearly have an
interest in and I honestly feel that you
shouldn't be chairing this and I think
you know it's bringing the council into
disrepute that is my thank you thank you
for that now I've lost my place to
answer it counselor
okay I'm going through will you let me
finish this item please okay well let's
see whose house the existence of nature
of any disclosable katooni interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to light
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the check
now to indicate and I will invite you to
speak and as you've kindly raised the
issue I do have an interest a bias in
agenda item on the motion and that is
why and I have already informed the
motion mover that it is my intention to
abstain from voting on that motion now
Tara is there anybody else indicating
they wish to declare an interest which a
motion yesterday's system counsel mrs.
China and counts a Dornan of all
requests to speak on this item right
sorry counselor maze first casting none
first Chancellor none thank you thank
you very much chairman items 7 and 12 in
so much as I'm currently a member of the
joint standards committee and the
declaration is of a non-pecuniary nature
thank you
then councillor maze does it Tara yes
teman got some eyes if we can contact
her cats amazed because she you I'm
sorry
bear with me chairman she's just gonna
put something on the chatter believe
right
[Music]
[Music]
council chairman council on the list
cast option counselor stamp yes please
Thank You chairman and I'd like to
declare well I think it's non-pecuniary
because I am pop trying to see you the
other weekend because I was very
concerned that you had resigned from the
conservative group and I did explain to
you chairman I thought you lived on your
own and I was very concerned that you
was on your own and understood the
severity of the decision you'd made so I
pulled a cabbage out of my garden and a
carrot and an onion and pop down to the
secret butchers and brought you some
banners and I think because of the way
that this motion seems to be turning on
its head at the moment and the things
that are happening behind the scenes
which I'm sure I'll get into trouble for
saying I want every member to know that
I popped to see the chairman because I
was concerned of his health and
well-being and if that's a criticism
then I think it's a sad state of this
council Thank You chairman thank you I
don't quite know whether that's a an
interest but thank you very much I
enjoyed the offerings and your company
we have now counselor thank you hello
Thank You chairman I wish to declare
non-pecuniary on any matter that might
be relating anyway to Essex County
Council but chairman on gender item
number 10 I feel I must also declare a
pecuniary interest on the Brad Welby
project stage 1 consultation I read the
consultation document chairman in some
degree of detail and on it there's a
great big circle of are several circles
and it may not be the case that
something will come there but that
circle part of it falls within the
village of all thorn and
not far it appears from where my
property lies so I have determined
speaking to the monitoring officer that
I am getting out chairman it may not go
there but I don't know so I'm leaving
the meeting
thank you mrs. chana and we've got a
long list still to go Tara who's next
sorry chairman chair on you there yes I
am sorry chairman could afternoon a very
straightforward interest I have a
non-pecuniary interest as a member of
Essex County Council anything pertaining
to any particular item on the agenda but
also a non-pecuniary interest as I'm
deputy cabinet member for for economic
development which includes planning and
clearly the Bramwell
Bramwell be consultation falls within
this portfolio thank you Thompson
councillor Thompson next all right
Castle it's why I've got before Counties
Thompson chairman but councillor miss
white Thank You mr. chairman I'd like to
declare an unsecured interest Knights in
the items six and twelve thank you
as I sat on the committee that's under
scrutiny effectively Thank You Council
mrs. Thompson next chairman - first
[Music]
oh I apologize for that I think it's
more full disclosure in that I am a
member of the joint standards committee
in fact I'm the chairman of it but I
didn't sit I wasn't a member of the
committee the last time it's at I
haven't had anything to do with the
report I haven't seen it
I haven't spoken I've been interviewed
in relation to it and as far as I know
I'm not mentioned so I think consular
hood did you want to add something
buzzing its ejected it's only on I think
counselor mr. white said she had an
interest in agenda item number six I've
got that down to cheering's
announcements okay I'm sure miss white
probably meant that seven did she know
she didn't leave got to seventh the
notice of motion I assume that mr. white
meant comes with Harker yes I've got
chairman thank you I've got the same as
you with emotion number seven so thank
you all right castor Jarvis as well Oh
councillor Jarvis councillor Jarvis
Thank You chairman and I was young i sat
in I was a substitute on joint Standards
Committee I don't know whether it's I
wasn't going to declare it as a Kinue
interest because obviously that's on
record at Council but other people seem
to be doing it so for the sake of
completeness we should have to be noting
thank you very much right then I think
we go on to agenda item four
which is the minutes of the meeting held
on the 28th of May 2024 mages 7 to 16
hour approved as a true and accurate
record I saw move if you wish to second
that motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone state your name
now please is that seconded Thompson
seconded to speak chairman can I just
give a small piece of advice to your
good self as chairman and to other
members to mute your microphone because
all members have heard or overheard a
conversation that took place on your
telephone a little while ago
be very careful thank you you're talking
about but I'm sure somebody else does
now this is a battery of accuracy and of
tarah we need to take a vote on this do
members wish to deal with this bias
ain't we okay thank you
it's agreed then right now we go on to
public questions right agenda item six
there now I have received no questions
from the members of the public then I go
on to agenda item seven I seem to have
to agenda item sevens Chairman's
announcements other than that I took
part in a flag-raising day week for the
Armed Forces week last Friday
there was a press release put out and
I'm sure members have seen it but we
have a great deal to our armed forces
both for what they do in defending the
country and protecting others in other
countries but recently with their work
from the mo D with the support for the
co behd pandemic and I think it's
particularly poignant that this was the
week that don't Vera Lynn died and thank
you and I now go on to the notice of
motion mrs. Stanton
yes Thank You chairman this is a motion
that myself and cancer Siddal put to the
council I wondered if capsule of flu
could like to describe it as what he did
on the personal phone call he made
before this nation motion started very
colorful introduction Council of Luca
and I'm very disappointed that you've
already made your mind up and was
speaking to somebody else on the phone
to say get it off the table I'm very
very upset about that obviously he's
already made a predetermined judge
judgment that he wants this motion of
the table before it is debated chairman
but I will continue and my emotion was
and I'll read it in its entirety member
so if you'll just forgive me or bear
with me put your camera on Wendy yeah it
really is better without it you actually
have got four motions I did tell you I
was gonna take it as one but there are
reasons which will come clear why I
can't okay
well I'll read it you want me to read it
chairman or would you yes that's your
prerogative yes thank you Oh cats the
keys Casa Kees joined us now welcome at
Moulton District Council has a statutory
duty to promote and maintain high
standards of conduct by its councilors
and cooperative members section 27 the
brackets to of the Localism Act 2011 the
Act requires a council to adopt code of
conduct it is not required in nor MDC to
adopt adopt a joint standards committee
but it is good practice and why wouldn't
they
in light of internal investigations I
propose the following motions to counsel
it states quite clearly chairman the
motions are better had been set out
separately for ease of vote of voting
now motion one and two stay the same but
motion three when it comes to it I would
invite catalyst Siddal to speak because
there's been an amendment if you will
allow him to do it chairman is that okay
yeah so far yep
I've made some rulings in a minute okay
well I'm sure you're ready because I do
know a little bit what's been going on
behind the scenes but there you go
motion to dispense the joint standards
committee in its current form and all
appointed councillors there's a motion
on the table chair are we taking that
now and we debating it yeah if you like
you can read out all your four motions
at once and then we'll go we'll go back
okay so that was nice members to disband
the joint standards committee in its
current form and are all appointed
councillors motion to do you want to
know somebody to speak or you waiting
I'm waiting for you to finish the
council waives the overall political
control of the authority political
balance to reconstitute the joint
standards committee motion three cats
the Siddall would you like to read
motion through the amendments of
chairman's you want me to read the old
one out well if you're if you're
amending your motion three mr. Crouch is
this permissible well chairman the the
motion is it's going to be amended you
firstly actually have to have the
original motion and then obviously
someone needs to go through the
amendment process thank you the
committee will consist of eight elected
members plus two parish council
observers no voting rights and the
independent person no voting rights it's
a 1 for members to be appointed from
both main parties each not excluding
non-alignment
or the political groups I think that was
amended check that would be amended
versus apologize
the committee will consist of eight
elected members fall from each political
group plus two parish council observe
there's no voting rights and the
independent person no voting rights
thank you thank you motion for the
chairman of vice Chairman's be pointed
not from the same political groups now
there was an amendment put forward
because of the Rory welcome I can we get
the formal second in on this council
ahead happy to second at Jim well I've
got councillor Sid alerts yes can I
please second it and can I also please
speak please I give the revised motions
well I have a right on the table you're
moving an amendment now please read the
amendment so before I read the amendment
I would really like to put my point of
view as well
I know Thank You chairman this motion
has been brought by myself and councilor
stump as an opportunity so that the
members of the council can work in a
cooperative and cohesive manner some
things like fairness and justice should
be above party politics and counsel
group dynamics these motions have
redesigns that the joint standards
committee in the future can operate in a
fair and balanced way this will
demonstrate that this council believes
in operating in a manner that is above
party politics and personal issues that
where there is an issue around conduct
and behavior that fair and reasonable
justice is seen to be done the people of
mold and district and the staff within
the council need to see that the members
of the council demonstrate excellent
conduct that we can set an example not
only in the way that we behave but not
in the way that we judge each other some
of the impression this council has
created recently has not been positive
and constructive where accounts were has
enjoyed internal joint standards of
committee it has to act in the most
professional and competent way possible
but
in these motions the council
demonstrates that this council wants to
join standards to act in this way and is
also constituted legally the Localism
Act of 2011 says that joint standards
committee is an ordinary committee an
orderly committee normally has to
reflect the overall political control of
authority the 2011 law also says that
this can be weighed by a vote of the
council this is the intention behind the
motion the dialogue and the impression
of modern district council needs to be
changed so that we are seem to be acting
the best interest of the district the
council and its members this goes beyond
political groups and tribalism since I
was selected as a candidate for the
Conservative Party I have been subjected
to untruths backstabbing and as the time
progressed up to last year's election
and since I was elected that turned into
more untruth direct and indirect belief
homophobia intimidation being undermined
stabbed in the front stabbed in the back
I have suffered stress and anxiety as a
result I have been bullied both verbally
and mentally and at times I've dreaded
what will happen next
even after I raise the complaint the
hobby or phobia of bullying was
continued in occluding remark that was
made last week as I remember who's been
subjects of repeated and constant acts
of misconduct I hope that for myself and
others that we make to understand this
committee that will consider any
complaints in a fair and just manner
this is what these emotions intend to do
the joy motion - just for parity does
not remove political balance from all
committees it is just for the joint
Standards Committee motion 3 will now
read this committee will consist of
eight elected members plus two parish
council observers no voting rights and
independent person no voting rights the
eight members should reflect the balance
of the membership of the council however
no group should have a majority on the
committee all political groups a group
is defined as three or more
representatives and is recognised as a
political entity within the council
should have representation
any substitutions must be made from the
same political group Thank You gentleman
yeah I don't know whether count Tara has
actually gotten out of that amendment
because it seemed to be rather calm you
lated and I didn't get it all and I
didn't quite follow it
Sahra did you pick it up at all I just
want amendment your other provision that
you're making
yesterday's the committee will consist
of eight elected members plus two parish
council observers no voting rights and
the independent person no voting rights
the eight members should reflect the
political balance of the membership of
the council however no group should have
the majority on the committee all
political groups a group is defined as
having three or more members and it
recognized as political entity within
the council should have representation
any substitutions must be made from the
same political group and then motion for
chairman for the time being I think that
I picked up some inconsistencies here
and is emotion suggesting that a
political group should be moved from two
people to three people because I think I
think that two people become a group and
there seems to be a dichotomy in the
motion where you say in one place it's
going to be politically balanced and
then another that no group has a
majority of members that seems to me and
mr. Kraus did you pick all this up
Bob just yes chairman and I agree with
you there seemed to be an inconsistency
in it that the eighth member should
reflect political balance although it
then does go on to say no shall have a
majority so I suppose what it's trying
to say is as far as is possible
the principles of political balance
should apply but not to the extent that
one group has a majority I think that's
what it's saying the intention yes
possibility in my view you can't have a
group of committee of eight members that
reflects the political balance as stands
at the moment the reflects of political
balance because I balance would be five
and three well I think actually chairman
if I may say if it's eight members my
calculations are that the the
conservative group at the moment have
four point zero eight members the
independent group would have three point
one two members and you've got to take
of the non-aligned they can't obviously
allocate but they still need to be taken
into account in the calculation and
that's not point eight with three non
eleven members so that translates
chairman to me into honor credit for
conservatives three and three
independence and one non-aligned member
which doesn't give a majority chairman
can I actually say that I think the
emotion needs to actually get some
credits that the non-aligned members are
now been included because they've never
been included before
yeah I'm getting I'm getting lot I'm
getting lots of requests to speak I
think the political balance argument
you can't have four point eight members
or one point to the normal rule is four
point eight you would round up to five
and and 3.2 you'd round down to three
that's a normal way because it also has
to take into account all the political
balance across the whole the whole
council for the moment I'll accept the
motion as as reworded right now I need
to open the debate to the members and
the first motion that we have of sorry
this is the issue of four motion for I
don't think that's been put formally yet
has it the chairman of vice chairman
will be appointed from the two largest
groups chairman that's what that says
yeah and and all this is always a
seconded by Councillor okay can we go
back to square one then and I'll take
each individual motion separately and so
the first the first motion is and to
disband the joint stand is committing
the current form and all appointed
councilors but we have got lots of
speakers and I'll take all four motions
as it were together although we will
vote separately on them is that
agreeable mr. Crouch no they all vote
separately surely that's absolutely
right Jim and you can actually have the
debate oh yeah and then at least one
that's correct that's quite an order
chairman
yeah right who's the first speaker Tara
and I can't speak
castle schemes council schemes hi yes
I'm very concise all right this whole
motion has my support complete support
because I'm very concerned about the
reputation of the council I am
particularly alarmed about the comments
that we heard from councillor felucca
before the meeting in which he said that
he wanted to get the motion overturned
get it off the table to quote we need to
get all this bollocks away please and
that to me is predetermination and I
think that excludes him from both the
debate and the voting and I want to make
the point that nobody who's currently on
the joint stands committee who have been
named in this report the names of which
have been released should be voting and
that council a voice and plate includes
you too didn't you hear my declaration
of interest councillor schemes I did but
I'm considered and that's fair that's
absolutely right oh man and I heard one
other but there are more to be heard
[Music]
thank you Thank You chairman chairman
I'm just sitting here confused and
bemused because I want to know what what
is going on where has all this come from
had a group meeting conservative group
meeting last week I asked the leader
about the existence of a report that has
been widely publicized by a lot of
people and and he said he was unaware of
the existence of a report exactly what
he said I'm afraid he said he wasn't
aware of a ripple or its contents and
I'm sure other group members will well
no that's not please let's keep this
sensible let's keep this adult and I
just can I please
is is there a report is there a ritual
questioning the probity of the last
joint standards committee yes or no
that's all I want to know because I want
to know how the health how we got here
thank you
jerilyn would you permit me hmm I think
this is an inappropriate forum for these
sorts of matters to be discussed they
they they they have no relevance in the
specific details and I think it is
inappropriate for members to ask
questions on these particular matters or
to give any indications whatsoever of
any investigations that are taking place
this is a motion that is independent of
all those matters it is a governance
motion and so in my view that members
should desist totally from any
indications innuendos or Express
statements about any investigations in
relation to any members thank you thank
you very much I know this motion was
designed to embarrass me as much as
possible but I am trying to know you
through it in a proper manner you please
be quiet chairman I do not speak to
embarrass you I do not seek to embarrass
any particular member I'm happy to
withdraw that question because mr.
Crouch has confirmed the existence of an
independent report thank you so much and
caps of three crews the next speakers
chairman Luka Thank You chip good
afternoon members and yeah look I agree
in principle to all of this but what
concerns me is how do we apply this to
our own governance and that's what
concerns me enormous Lee I mean look
Council acetal made a very very
passionate statement on and I agree with
most of these but he was talking about
fairness and cohesion and the the latest
the live
three which i've got in front of me
it's basically excludes anybody that's
not aligned that's what this actually
does unless they're in a political group
of more than three now we know that some
own constitution a political group has
to be too and then you certainly get
allocation and rights and everything
else but there is this exclusion and I'm
very very uncomfortable to think that as
we move through this administration if
for any reason they are members that
don't want to sit in the political group
they want to sit on their own they could
be totally excluded now where we are
counsel okay I have to stop you counsel
the swine has raised a point of order
council swine what's your point of order
it must relate to rules
I wish to I wish to ask for a vote on
whether we take the motions individually
or together we're dealing with the
motion all four motions in one debate
but we will be voting individually need
to have a motion to vote yeah Thank You
Jimmy and say you know what my
overarching point is at the moment this
the way this motions then the moment it
is going to exclude three members from
participating in this this Standards
Committee now going forward that could
more but the easy at the moment it is
10% of the council will be excluded from
the count from the stoners community now
in my mind that cannot be right and yeah
I do feel passionate about that because
I don't want to see anybody treated in
that way they're a member of this
council they should have every right on
the committee if possible
so yeah I don't agree with that part of
motion three but I've made it absolutely
clear everything else this is a hugely
complicated matter chairman and I'm sure
that as as this debate goes on I think
if we come more and more complicated
because I've been involved in
conversations with the monitoring
officer being involved in conversation
with others over the last few days and
this whole thing has evolved and it is
it's quickly becoming a constitution or
a procedural nightmare
my nephew is chairman is that we should
send this resolution which as I said I
agree of motion which I agree with in
principle we send it to performance
governance and audit that's why we had
this committee the Governance Committee
will send it to the performance and
Governance Committee they can go through
this motion they can make it absolutely
watertight and fair for everybody on
this council and then come back to
council chairman with their
recommendations and that is what I think
we should do and that is what I was
alluding to earlier we need to have a
property bake around this in the
Governance Committee Chairman so I'm
afraid that based on that I have a
different view but of course come on
lined always remains open and so such
times as I've heard the whole debate
Thank You mr. chairman that's word yes
that's right chairman councilor heard
please can you hear me okay yeah right
yeah okay hammer on mark there we are
first of all I'm astounded by councilor
feluccas newfound concern for non party
members and ever since may May 20 19
here nor would the fundamental level of
democracy by refusing to work with the
independent group to represent the
district even though we represent a
hundred percent of more than 75% of
Birnam 50% of all thorn South Minster
and average we had no joint manifesto
and no personal issues with the
conservative group but we have
encountered huge resistance from the
leadership who saw us only as opponents
and not partners the election result
must have been a shock to them but the
leadership had been designed to keep
Outsiders out and those in charge in
complete charge
now on most committees we accepted that
we were represented as the lesser party
but this has not been effective fair or
indeed legal in the case of the joint
standards committee so in order for this
council to demonstrate true impartiality
when addressing internal matters and
issues political balance must be shared
50/50 not 5 to 1 against how can this be
true open and transparent the issue is
not Wingull conservative support
conservatives or independents support
independence but it's the individual
right or wrong if they are gone then
they should be found to do so but you
can't do this by directing members or
whipping them to comply if we aren't
agreed to work together for what is
right and what is wrong there is no hope
for us so I hope that counts that is
look at these
I hope the clouds this will look at
these motions and consider them very
carefully for the best interest of
counsel and not personal gain thank you
Karen
Thank You councillor heard Tara who's
next a Frankie championed and Catholic
Basinger is next and then else will
passenger Thank You mr. chair
mr. Chairman I would like to also give
my full support to this motion and I
think it's about time that this motion
was really brought to to say exactly
what it was meant to be it's about
fairness at being probably the only
counselor apart from councilor Sidel of
course that has experienced as far as
I'm concerned bullying I've been as far
as I'm concerned as well persecuted I
went through the joint standards
committee and I've felt absolutely
ever since that since that judgement
that found me guilty for something
absolutely ridiculous such as not really
really being aware of what I was doing
apparently or something and making the
wrong declaration I was reported to the
police but that was by a majority of
conservatives and I felt that it was so
unfair and I've had stress and I felt as
though I've been able to speak freely
ever since and I think this motion is
exactly what this council needs I think
we need to show some home of fairness
and I think the public need to see that
we are a Council that is acting fairly
so I absolutely strongly hope that
everyone else will support this motion
okay Tara who's next
Thank You chairman sorry it takes me a
minute to get everything on I have no
problem with this motion except the part
two and I think it would be better I
know the intention is that this should
only relate to joint standards committee
but the way it reads it could be
construed to mean the whole council so I
think it just needs to say in relation
to the joint standards committee and
then the rest of it just to make it
doubly clear that it is just in relation
to joint standards committee so that's
what I'm proposing and apart from that I
am happy to agree this motion
councillor Bamford Tara next please
there's someone second that chairman you
can't you can't my second cats LaBelle
you can't you can't make an amendment
until there's something to amend and at
the moment we've got amend
well we already amended motion three yes
sorry yeah okay
I'll read I'll review that and your your
amendment was to which part
it's to part to motion to just to add at
the beginning in relation to the joint
standards committee only okay okay
that's a semi councillor belt to Jenna
would it help if so chairman
sorry to interrupt chairman just to help
the amendment motion - could we just if
this is what members want to do could it
just read that the council waves and
then knock out the words the overall
political control of the authority waves
council waves the political balance of
political balance to reconstitute the
joint standards committee then it's
clear with that suggested amendment by
Simon coach thank you okay right great
I'll assume for the moment that that's
accepted by council and we won't need to
vote on that just yet but I'll include
that as the as the second motion if mrs.
Stamp and mr. city councilors in lower
grade counselors temp do you agree that
I do mention I do I do and I think
that's a bamford for trying to find out
a resolution thank you and I also
support it chairman thank you we go ara
to who's next
now since this channel its next chairman
this is Jana sorry chairman I was just
trying to come in there chairman just to
say I'm very clear that this isn't
anything to do with some independent
report it may be in existence or not I
certainly haven't seen one however I
think we've heard what kept mr. Crouch
said on that score and councillor Daren
withdrew that question this motion is
what is important before the council and
what this motion is trying to achieve is
quite clear to me it's a to abandon the
joint standards committee as it sits in
constituted currently and to
reconstitute it mr. Crouch's just added
clarity to motion to which I should say
was a concern to me in council
Brentford's covered that off and then
the other area motion three we've heard
about an amendment there a motion forth
to me it's quite straightforward what
this is all about the current standards
the committee does not remain its
reconstituted it's fairly done to have
representation across the council and
then move forward with that chairman I
think that's what the essence is all
about Tara who who's next
Kassar Jarvis is next chairman council
Jarvis thanks chairman I just wanted to
say that I'll pick up on a few points I
mean in general I gave my I think I
minded to give my support to the motions
that have been put forward and have
noted the comments from councillor
Basinger and obviously I think
councillor Bamford's amendment is also
appropriate as we've heard from the
monitoring officer I just like to pick
up on I think probably the only
outstanding query that I've heard which
councillor Luca raised regarding
unaligned representation of course in an
ideal world that would be the case but
all all council is here our unaligned
and therefore having to say stated
themselves with a particular group I
find it difficult to see
in trying to achieve as fair as the
overall issue that we're trying to
achieve I find it difficult to see
unless you wanted a council
mathematically that had you know about
20 people on it a committee that I had
20 people on it how you could actually
achieve that so I think this is a
compromise on that particular point but
I think the overall objective here is to
have a committee that is seen to be fair
and I think in that respect I know that
the unaligned wouldn't have
representation on this committee but I
think the overall objective still works
Thank You Gerry thank you Taro's next
fleming chairman Joe Fleming Thank You
chair I just wanted to record my
amusement that council of frankerz marks
thank you can I have next telegin Thank
You chair the speakers in another line
member elesif or the emotions that have
been put forward and we're debating this
afternoon because time for collaboration
in this council I also very much like
councillor Fleming with accounts for
their focus comments before hand because
the viciousness of self-interest in the
politics have been played since that
they many of us elected members walked
through the door of that chamber full of
hope that we could actually be a
collaborative force for good and change
where has been a challenging Council
with a challenging reputation
it really does sum up why we need to
change why we need to get this motion
through so that we are representative
that we are not sensibly fair we are
fair and that we stand for the things
that we were elected for rather than
politics and I'm very very very happy to
support what's been discussed this
afternoon and be very very happy to
discuss my support when we get the
chance for new leadership Thank You
chair and
Chandran I've got castle this is time
someone's to come back in relation to
comic cancer passenger made Thompson um
thank you no I'm not gonna come back I
might do that by email it's gonna get to
comple Thank You Tara have we anybody
else that's my hat chairman right now I
believe the procedure would normally be
for the leader to have a say and then
for the motion mover to have the summing
up and counsel of Luca do you wish to
say anything further at this stage
chairman no but I'm quite well no yes
I'm quite pleased to see where the where
the debates going and I think we're sort
of sorting everything out I hear what
councillor laggin says and also carve
councillor Jarvis said about the
exclusion and non-aligned members it's a
shame that we still haven't worked out a
way of doing that you know to me a
simple way would be to do it would be to
juggle the the political balance taking
non-aligned as a collective and
allocating them probably one or however
many seats but making sure that overall
the majority doesn't rest with one with
one party the other thing chairman is
and looking at the chair I think that we
we've had and you know and I hope no
mansion officer will come back to that
comment because to see if there is a way
that we can possibly do this but I think
because we've had a minutes it might be
a good idea chairman before we vote that
we have the elements put up so members
fully understand what they're voting on
thank you mrs. stem would you please
move your motion yes I'd like to thank
all members that had showed no prettiest
predetermination to throw it out the
window before it was actually on the
table and debated it fully so I do thank
you all for that
and I think the other councillors all of
them spoke absolutely fantastic and
eloquently and everybody
knew the spirits of what this motion was
whether this some little nitpicking
areas that need to be strengthened by
mr. Quelch and the excellent team of
horses we've got they could accompany as
that but the essence is quite clearly as
the other members said we want to be
seen to being open and transparent and
fair your point of order and I hope it
relates to statute or our rules yes it
does chairman this is actually procedure
rules one it's found on page 121 of the
Constitution that the opposition leader
will be the penultimate speaker fair
point and I apologize mrs. Stamp do you
wish to stop and counselor herd to have
a say of course I do I'll give way to
cat so heard yeah thank you counselor
please continue Thank You chairman it's
it's really just to say to all members
that this is an opportunity to be true
and honest so this council and I do hope
that when they do vote that they will
take that into consideration I also note
councilor feluccas words at the start of
this and I'd like to make it clear that
as far as the independent group are
going this is a completely free vote
thank you
councilor stamp sorry for the
interruption please continue chairman
you won't be surprised at my age I've
lost me flow but I know you're feeling
very well and yes I just really want to
say thank you and you've all got to vote
with the the idea of the spirit is there
there may be some tweaking and I hope
that we are allowed to tweak or the
officers can help us to make sure
this motion chairman was never ever
designed to exclude anybody we've worked
hard to try and do this and you know
it's me it's the best of the council and
I hope that all the members choose to
support it and I'd love a recorded vote
on every motion please okay is that ii
did okay ii did yeah thank you
right then we can proceed to take the
first vote on the first motion tarah
will you call the roll yes Janice is
voting on motion one and I will call the
names out and if you can just respond if
you're four against or abstaining please
thank you so starting with I'm sorry to
cut it could we see this motion one is
unchanged its to disband the joint
standards committee in its current form
and all appointed councillors it does
away with the Standards Committee as is
constituted at the moment
carry on Tara please Thank You chairman
a Casa Bamford or the Basinger or miss
Beale for Brian for voice abstain
counselor mrs. Chema just coming in
sorry for cancer Joo ik oh so you can
sit down is for I can see from holding
up Catholic
Oh for so Freaker for
abstain or you cancer he'll stay cats
the keys for cancer lager or you cancer
maze cancer maze for just to confirm
that [ __ ] thank you Thank You counsel
Morley for okay councillor Morris
definitely fall keep counselor none for
Thank You counselor the CE o it all for
four damn oh it's for you cancer Swain
for castle mrs. Thompson for cancer miss
white Thank You Terra I'm going to
abstain because it's a a I have an
interest in this matter so I don't feel
I can vote on it thank you
so chairman the results of the vote in
relation to motion one is twenty four in
favor so for a six abstaining and nobody
against and Thank You Terra that motion
is therefore carried can we move on now
to I believe an amended motion to was it
yes Jen animation to did you want me to
put it on the screen for one moment
so this is motion to as amended I am
that's my understanding of how it was
amended okay members see that please
call the roll gentleman magic bounce to
know wording that counts Simon Crouch
advised the council waves political
balance to really constitute the joint
standards committee yes chairman that's
what I suggest it's just the removal of
the words the overall political trolling
I think that's where the confusion was
yes some members so removing that the
council waves political balance to
reconstitute it's a bit in eloquent but
I think it's clear okay sure not quite
sure chairman that it is clear it might
be better to say the council waves
political balance on the joint standards
committee in order to reconstitute it
fair enough I think that's that's
reasonable votes yes a farce it's only
relates to the joint standards committee
though we can now vote on that tarah
okay done your magic okay you you've
cost to reconstitute you need to take
out reconstitute I think yesterday or
move it somewhere else
the cat's away someplace good balance on
the joint Standards Committee in order
to reconstitute it is that is that how
callous yeah okay are you happy for me
to take the vote in our Chairman okay
and as before members are cool names
alphabetically if you could just advise
if you are for against or abstaining
thank you very much
starting the Caliban third degrees for
brass injure or
absolutely spiel for bail for place
abstain counsel mrs. Trenor for cancer
Duke
thank you cancer Darrin for cancer are
you I'm not able to get on okay all
right I'm for Tara for cancer frico
for that's the Harker for for the helm
abstain counselor how for comics for
that's the keys for I'm so lacking for
please sir oh yeah
cancer morally for this most definitely
for Thank You counselor none for cancer
Shaughnessy that's the pseudo genes for
counselors stamp
oh sorry damn it yes for Vicky cancer
stilts
poor poor cancer mrs. Thompson
mrs. Thompson thank you
cancer miss white abstain 26 for nobody
again through four abstentions that gets
me out of a major problem
Thank You Tara we then move on to the
amended motion 3 which you have on your
screen
yes chairman is everybody familiar with
that okay
please take the role members just if you
could advise three or four against or
abstaining
starting with cancer Bamford please Paul
becomes a passenger or repeal cancer
bill or you can suffice abstain she's
chana or Jarek cancer Darin for Edwards
cancer mrs. Fleming for hey abstain
cancer herd for cancer hell I'm staying
home abstain after Jarvis for cancer
keys or
thank you so much
sorry okay
I'm cancer miss white abstain thank you
emotion three is abstaining that's
carried then we move on straight the
straight forward motion for could you
take the roll please
Tara yes chairman as before members
starting because the benefit place for
thank you cancer passenger or you can
appeal for Vicki Katz labelled the
castle voice of Stein
thank you Katsura sees chana for you
can't saduak stays
Turin for cancer Edwards
whoo screaming whoa
that's a flicker for the Hawker abstain
ahead for capsule home staying cancer
Jarvis
oh that's the keys for cancer nagging
oh please Dora thank you thanks the race
for you can't Simoni for some ice
definitely for eat counselor none for
cancer Shaughnessy for dumb for cancer
schemes poor Thank You cancer step and I
can actually say for myself tower don't
need somebody whisper in my ear to tell
them to abstain turn your microphones
off if you get in coaching members you
can systemic or swing cool so mrs.
Thompson sorry for Miss Wright abstain
then it's my own decision to stay and I
haven't had to speak to anybody else
Thank You chairman the results of the
vote for motion 424 for nobody against
and six abstentions thank you Thank You
Terra that motion is carried
also we now I think don't have the need
for agenda item 12 mr. Krause is this
correct that that's right chairman can I
just make an observation and as
that might I hope will be helpful
obviously now there is no there is no
membership of joint standards committee
all members have been removed so for the
July meeting the groups the two the two
groups will have to put forward their
nominations although political balance
doesn't apply we've got to try and
follow the principles according to the
resolution giving no group of majority
my calculations mean with a membership
of eight this a conservative group have
four nominations the independent group
have three and the council must put in
one non-aligned member now the
non-aligned membership is not a group
but the council has to put a non-aligned
member on JSA okay mr. Kuo
thank you for your advice but I think
the determination of this should should
go to the relevant parties because it
doesn't form part of although it makes
sense what you're saying
I don't think it's appropriate at this
time and because I remember the advice
that we had asked my that a non-aligned
person had no rights to a seat on any
committee so I want that to be
established that that non-aligned
members do have a right so if we can
leave your advice for the time being for
the councilor heard at Council of Lucca
and councillor Morris legen and myself
to sort out that's a really valid point
you said if I can just come in one
second before we move on because Council
of flucos who is saying is pouting so
much about the non-aligned well you are
absolutely right they haven't had any
representation until now and we've
agreed that they should be a
representation so it's very very easy
yeah yeah but only on as I understand it
only so far on the joint Standards
Committee anyway can we can we longest
on a line counselor
I think that's gotta be making isn't it
well counselor Morris yeah yeah I don't
have your turn erupted yeah yeah if you
say so
counsel Morris that sounds in JC nuclei
ville
what's the point exactly discussed that
what item 12 there's no need for that we
won't be having it and count mr. Krause
that was correct wasn't it yes that's
correct
a chairman there is no need now for
agenda item 12
but thank you then we go on to agenda
item 8 minutes of meetings of the
council to note that since the last
council meeting up till Monday the 15th
of June council agenda the following
committees have met and to receive any
questions in accordance with council
committee procedure rules six to so
there any any questions under 16 right
and Taro's any membrane indicated to
vote general item 9 questions in
accordance with procedure rules 6 3
which noticed has been given there's I'm
advised that there's no such questions
we now go to agenda item 10 Fred will be
project stage 1 consultation council
attorney you're living them yes I'm just
can cateura confirm that I hang out I'm
hanging up now
it's chairman I can't confirm that
cancer is China has now left the meeting
she's still on my screen mr. frozen um
hmmm and I also have a non-pecuniary
interest as I already declared retaining
the moment I'll call on the leader of
the council to present this item I
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please make the this down by
using the chat function within this
meeting I will then come to you in turn
following the leader of the council's
presentation please keep your points
clear and succinct leader
thank you chairman before I hand over to
the officers and can I can I thank
George inna button and Gavin kings north
and their teams for the enormous amount
of work that's gone into this you know
we've had a lot of push for breadboard
way to meet deadlines I know that
they've been extended because of the
health emergency but nevertheless they
have got this report together it's a
great tribute to everybody that's made a
contribution and not least of all the
officers from Essex County Council as
it's a joint report so chairman with
that I'll defer to the director of
strategy perform no and forth yes G
stretchy performance and governance and
thank you very much thank you Jim Thank
You leader I don't need to tell members
what an important issue the proposed
development of Brad will be nuclear
power station is for Malden District
Council and the residents of the
district given the importance of this
issue
I've asked officers to present some
further detail on the report which
they'll be doing following my
introduction this report seeks
endorsement to a recommended response to
the stage 1 consultation relating to the
proposed Brad will be power station
proposals as set out in the appendices
of this report the joint member Brad
well board made a recommendation that a
joint consultation response be provided
representing the views of both mold and
district councillor and Essex County
Council and the board also endorsed the
specific response now recommended to
council the joint response has also been
considered by the corporate governance
working sorry not the corporate
governance the council's Brad will be
power station working group accordingly
following collaborative work between
each or thority the recommended joint
responses before council for its
approval before handing over to officers
though I wanted to highlight the context
of the consultation modern District
Council are a console T in this process
and as such will not be determining the
outcome of the application process the
pros the proposed development of the
bride will be nuclear power station is
considered a nationally significant
infrastructure project nationally
significant infrastructure projects are
covered by the Planning Act 2008 which
advises the secretary of state that any
decision starts with relevant national
planning policies this is different to
the legislative basis for planning
applications under the Town and Country
Planning Act 1990 which starts on the
basis that decision decisions are made
in accordance with the development plan
national policy documents therefore
provide the key basis for
decision-making on planning applications
for development consent orders for
nuclear power stations and these
national policies are the overarching
national policy statement for energy
July 2011 in the national policy
statement for nuclear power generation
July 2011 MPs en six MPs en six explains
that there is an urgent need for nuclear
power stations and that nuclear power
forms aunt an important element of the
strategy towards achieving a more
decarbonized secure and diversified
electricity sector by 2050 it also
identifies Brad will be as one of the
eight potentially suitable sites for a
nuclear power station in England and
Wales before the end of 2025 mps n en 1
confirms that all planning applications
for nuclear power stations shall be
assessed on the basis that the
government has demonstrated that there
is a need for this infrastructure Molden
district councillors local development
plan adopted in july to 2017 has only
one policy in reference to a new nuclear
power station policy d 4 states that the
council will strongly support the
principle of
the development of new nuclear power
station at Bradwell on C this is the
policy context in which the consultation
response has been developed not on the
principle of whether there should be a
development as that's already
established in national policy but on
the basis of commenting on the proposals
that have been brought forward in
developing the consultation response
officers have looked to provide
responses that seek to maximize the
socio-economic benefits of the project
and minimize the negative impact of the
proposals the response is based on the
consultation document provided by BRB as
part of the public consultation the
level of detail in the consultation
document has meant that the response is
necessarily high level often pointing
out where additional information will be
required highlighting particular
sensitivities in areas requirement
significant further work this
consultation is stage one of a two stage
consultation process and more detail
will be provided at stage two and that
will be the formal statutory element of
the consultation as part of the DCO
process I'll now hand over to Georgina
button and cabin Kings North who provide
further details on the response itself
Georgina
thank you Paul
so as to just what Paul has just shared
with you and to in some way just
reiterate some of that so in 2010 the
government announced that Bravo was one
of the eight sites it considered
suitable in principle for the siting of
a new new nuclear power station and as
Paul said within the local development
plan it's the stating policy D for
renewable and low-carbon energy
generation that there is support from
the council in principle in the joint
response we recognize that the
developments potential importance at a
local regional and national level and
that the council's supports the
government's amos sustainable
development mitigating climate change
and of course achieving good design
it also states in the response that the
council will seek to maximize the
benefits from the proposals while also
seeking to avoid or minimize potential
negative impacts compensation airy
measures will be sought where
appropriate and a positive lasting
legacy from the development is
considered essential if it is to become
an example of sustainable development to
progress this work the council has
commitments the development plan
document to address the development
needs potentially rising from the rubble
redevelopment now in the terms of the
development consent order process the
project is at stage 1 pre-application
nonsti is a non statutory public
consultation in which as you can see is
taking place issue it's the first stage
of a two-stage process of
pre-application consultation as paul has
already said stage 2 next year we'll see
a statutory consultation carried out and
we'll publish preferred options
alongside detailed assessments and
priority stages strand strategies after
the pre-application consultation BRB
will then decide whether to proceed and
submit the development consent
application to the planning inspector at
this point unresolved issues can be
raised through representatives to the
Planning Inspectorate and at this point
the council will be required to submit a
local impact report the Planning
Inspectorate then will produce a report
for the Secretary of State for decision
and this is due to take place the
following year in 2022
in terms of the council's governance
structure officers are engaging with the
bread will be member group the joint
member Brad will board which includes
representatives from Essex County
Council and brings reports to Council
for decisions in the joint response
report brought to Council today you will
hopefully see the level of work officers
have achieved in a short time and in
unprecedented circumstances the
development consent pre application is a
lengthy process that process and in the
next 18 months is going to be both fast
paced
and certainly an intense amount of work
that will require us to have an informed
vision and a clear view of what we do
want and don't want for the district I'm
now going to hand over to Gavin Kings
North our development consent order
technical lead to take you through the
joint response in more detail
Thank You Georgina and good afternoon
members or just commence the
presentation the report now before
council summarizes the proposals that
that are the subject of the current
stage one consultation and they're now
planned to take you through key
components of the proposal the slides I
will show you have been taken directly
from be Arby's consultation material and
so you may have seen them before this
slide shows the main development sites
and outlined in red members will see
that the site is very large a total of
some 230 hectares it is located to the
south and east of the decommissioned
Bradwell a power station highlighted
here on the plan the northern boundary
extends along the Blackwater s tree
until it meets the ortho 'no community
and the chapel of some peters on the
wall it then follows the north of East
End Road to the east of Brad well long C
village and then touches upon waterside
Road before it then returns back to the
Blackwater s tree to the east of Brad
world village the site sits within an
environmentally sensitive area valued
for its landscape history and importance
for ecology site impacts nationally and
internationally important designations
for nature and some Peters Chapel is of
national importance as a grade 1 listed
building the esterline landscape is
valued by both the local community and
visitors to the area with the public
footpath along the seawall often used
Bradwell a is a landmark in the
landscape seen from far afield both from
leisure craft enjoying the black water
and from the land both within the Morton
district from neighboring authorities to
the north the former brand well by
airfield is also part of the value
history of the site and the main run
well runway can be seen from this slide
this slide is an aerial view taken from
the west of the site looking east it
shows on your part of the main site but
is included to illustrate the massive
scale and extent of the site and the
character of the area the former
airfield is clearly seen and the the RAF
War Memorial is also evident and trusses
Road and parent with the current access
roads of Bradwell a on the left the
former airfield control tower can also
be seen in the mid distance to the right
this slide is a 3d computer-generated
image taken from VR bees fly through
which is available on its website
website it is a similar direction from
the previous slide looking from the west
to east we trust his road to the right
and Bradwell a to the left the image
illustrates the main proposals for the
permanent power station on the site the
two reactor buildings and associated
turbine halls are shown in the centre
when fully operational the station would
generate or produce 2.2 gigawatts of
electricity enough to power around 4
million homes this slide also shows the
intention to site power station further
inland and Bradwell ie this has been
influenced by the ecological sensitivity
of sensitivity of the estuary
and also the flood risks associated with
benefits associated with siting on
higher land the existing flood defences
along the s3 will will not be affected
and the and the proposed proposals
include standalone flood defences around
the power station this image also shows
the Arby's decision to you
use hybrid cooling towers rather than
direct cooling from the s3 this again
has been driven by the ecological
sensitivities of the estuary including
the need to avoid significant changes in
water temperature from direct calling
they are they expresses a preference for
call circular cooling towers and Lygia
as shown on the image the reactor
building buildings would be the largest
and tallest buildings on the site up to
60 metres in height and will be
prominent in the landscape cooling
towers would be a similar height we've
broader width and idaite diameter they
would have a greater impact than
Bradwell a due to the scale and number
of buildings will be visible locally
both locally and further afield within
the Bourdon district and beyond there's
the island and other communities to the
north of the Blackwater we'll have a
clear view of the proposed power station
this slide shows the indicative land
layouts of the Power Station in plan
form the proposed standalone flood
defences perhaps more clearly shown
envelope in the Power Station site
proposed main access from waterside Road
can also be seen which would avoid the
need for traffic to use trustees Road as
is the current access to Bradwell a the
power station plans to be operational
for a minimum period of 60 years during
that time the consultation predicts
approximately 900 permanent jobs with a
further thousand jobs during periods
Vantage for servicing and maintenance
this would be a strong positive for the
district's economy I will now move on to
addressing the construction stage of the
proposals whilst there are no firm
details in the consultation the overall
message is clear it will be a massive
undertaking over many years the
construction period is expected to be
between nine to twelve years and
approximately six million tons of
construction materials are expected to
be required marine transport is seen as
a major component to supply the site
with a consultation indicating that at
least 50% of the bulk materials would
arrive by sea on-site was the plan
currently on screen shows proposals for
land restoration in green for landscaped
areas and ecological benefits this area
of the site would be required during the
construction period for construction
equipment and plant particularly to the
west or waymarks river was shown here
soil storage and redistribution
redistribution is indicated on the land
to the south and east as part of this
the stage 1 consultation highlighted
here to make use of marine transport
landing facilities will be required and
the construct consultation proposes up
to two facilities with a preference
indicated for beach landing facilities a
permanent landing facility is shown to
the west of Radwell a that during the
construction period a second is shown to
the east approximately here to serve the
main construction area this slide
illustrates the Arby's proposals for a
beach landing facility which is
preferred over more substantial options
involving jetty structures it shows a
landing platform on the shore bed around
which delivery barges could offload
during high tide a trestle bridge would
then bridge over the existing flood
defense to the construction site on
shore the maximization of sustainable
transport is a key aim for the project
as the more freight that can be
accommodated by marine or rail the less
the less will need to be accommodated on
the highway this underlies the council's
stress place on the well on a
well-developed and robust sustainable
transport strategy prior to the
discussions on details on highway
proposals VRB has identified constraints
associated with rail transport but the
council's are seeking a thorough
assessment of all options to drive down
potential freight traffic on roads
there will however remain a need for a
substantial amount of road traffic on
the highway the consultation estimates
between 500 to 700 two-way hgv movements
a day this is a substantial number of
HGV movements and will be challenging
for the highway network to accommodate
there will be there will be a need to
move Freight between the primary road
network and the main construction site
and the consultation proposal sets out
some initial proposals for routes and
options during the early works stage
stage of the proposals which is normally
within the first three years and when
major improvements would not have been
carried out on the highway there is a
proposal for HGV route traveling in by
the a12 and the for one for the B one
one zero one eight ten eighteen and then
travelling eastwards to the site it
would then return by the same route but
but branch off south coming to the B 10
12 and the a three one two before
joining the a 135 South wooden ferries
during the main construction period the
southern route is the preferred route
using the a 130 a 1/3 to route with a
number of options considered within the
Morden district broadly with the blue
routes following the existing larger
roads with potential improvements and
the red route further south using less
world traffic routes and longer new
routes support for the blue route is
considered appropriate and this in
principle support includes consideration
of highway improvements and potential
bypasses on the blue routes in order to
manage HGV movements on the highway
network the consultation proposes
management facilities to hold HGVs so
flows on the network can be managed the
consultation illustrates three potential
search areas with it likely that only
one will be needed within the Morton
district the size of a freight
management facility is identified as
approximately 10 to 15 hectares to
accommodate between 100 to 150 HGTV's
this slide shows the two search areas
within the Morden district covering a
large area between cold north and
mainland the construction stage will not
only need a large quantity of
construction material it will also need
a very large workforce during
construction it is estimated that there
could be between nine thousand one
hundred and ten thousand six hundred
workers needed on site which three
thousand are expected to come from the
local area some workers will be home
base but many others will need
accommodation the proposals therefore
include includes temporary workers
accommodation close to the main
development site to provide
approximately 4,500 bed spaces this
slide show shows sites that are being
considered by b.i B with its preference
for site one with a potential to expand
into site 2 even with this large
temporary workers accommodation campus
it is expected that the scale of the
project will impact on the modern
district housing market as with Freight
there will also be a need to promote a
sustainable transport for the moment of
workers the RB will will be assuming
that some home-based workers will be
prepared to travel to work for up to 90
minutes and so there is some potential
for travel from some distance away one
part of the sustainable approach to the
movement of workers is the provision of
Park and Ride sites and this slide shows
the broad locations being considered by
BRB the Park and Ride sites these sites
would pick up park cobble workers with
onward bus travel to the main site this
would reduce the
vehicles on the highway Network three
sites are being considered within the
modern district to which of the same
search areas for the freight management
facility and the third to the west of
Maldon I hope that this presentation has
adequately summarized the main
components of the power station
proposals that are subject to this
consultation and raise some of the
topics that the council's will need to
address going forward to maximize the
benefits and minimize the negative
effects of the scheme may have finished
by confirming that the stage 1
consultation by BRB has come at an early
stage of the Brad will be power station
schemes development and the development
consent order process the consultation
is welcomed as an introduction to the
emerging proposals and will support
future engagement between BRB and the
council and other stakeholders going
forward as more robust strategies detail
baseline assessments and detailed impact
assessments are prepared the recommended
Joint Council response to the stage 1
consultation will provide a firm basis
for future pre-application discussions
with the RB as the project progresses
beyond this early stage of consultation
and towards the statutory Stage 2
consultation
[Music]
[Music]
need to unmute yourself Bob Bob be a
muted I thought there was only a handful
and later yeah chairman thank you very
much and I just wanted to take before we
have a for debate I just want to echo
the words and the offices really that
we're not deciding the planning
application here we decided in a
response and of course this is the
non-statutory response but but
nevertheless deaths nevertheless German
I'd like to put the members in their
comfort zone if I can this thing to
accelerate very quickly towards us as
members so I would propose to him that
we had a another recommendation
recommendation Roman 3 that members
regularly consulted with at the start of
the DCO stage to consultation process
which is the statutory consultation and
I believe that members should be
involved light at the beginning of this
so that we can understand and see what
is in the statutory consultation
otherwise determine to start the debate
I would propose that we agree these two
recommendations and the third one that
I've just proposed thank you thanks very
much Tara I don't know whether it would
be helpful for members to have these
recommendations up on the screen while
we go through the debate but until we
make a decision on that would you like
to tell me who the first speaker should
be after the leader the first speaker is
councillor Swain chairman thank you
Thank You councillor swooned Thank You
chairman there is comments firstly
initially mr. Dodson mentioned that it
was a joint thing with Walden district
and County Council
he didn't mention how closed it jumps
but might have been involved though of
course there is mention in the report of
the difficulties particularly around
down
and of course in cases with south rhythm
terrors as a general point I I'm
concerned that some of the wording of
the report tends to confuse statements
that are effectively made by BRB or
which are as we say government
statements with what the council's
comments are on the situation they tend
to get confused on the specific point
about the 90 minute radius for people
traveling to this site I think it
grossly underestimate traffic problems
in that 90 minute radius therefore I
think over a novus estimates the
willingness of people to drive for that
time the implication of course is that a
much larger encampment may be required
and greater pressure on local housing
one could foresee that a lot of
residents might well decide to move and
wind their houses out to people working
at the site
one cannot be impressed when reading the
documentation by the offices that have
gone into this how destructive and
devastating the traffic will be on the
road network damage to infrastructure as
well as impact on communities and on the
environment as well as further afield
tamama and this is symptomatic of the
lack of ground work that's been done on
this project and should have been done
at a much earlier stage there were very
many requirements for information
modeling and so on in the report and
which if they had been done earlier
might have not led to Bradley Bedwell
being picked on as a site at all I say
picked on in a colloquial sense because
it seems to me the decision to pick on
Bedwell was not a thoroughly thought out
I do in the first place
with the extent of the investigations
and modeling that seemed to be required
and information gathering there were
seem to be two possibilities here
whether we could request will require
some important elements of that to be
undertaken before any planning
application is considered or whether we
could engage many of those requirements
for information as conditions in a
planning application when it comes to
counsel I don't want to cut you off but
there's a lot of members want to split
you've asked a lot of questions okay and
we will not have the final decision
planning wise no and my last point is I
would like to suggest an amendment a
small amendment of wording in one
paragraph at some stage either now or
later in the proceedings but if you give
it to us now mr. mr. Kings no fkin
answer hopefully one or two of your
questions and and give his views on your
amendment the amendment that I would
like to put two members on page 28
paragraph three point five point five
and it would be to delete some of the
wording mr. Kings don't I remember I
would like to delete the phrase or
clause confirms councils support for the
development and mr. Kings elf would you
like to respond to the questions that
are in there
Thank You chairman I think the one of
the issues was raised about the 90
minutes travel time and I think I tried
to make it clear that that would be an
outside limit that's assumed for
construction workers and the and it's
based
on construction workers willingness to
travel to work but it isn't assuming
that everybody that that distance would
want to travel to that work there the
Arby's going to have a a gravity model
which effectively the closer you get to
the site the more likely they believe
people would would travel to the site so
the humber home workers that may well be
living 90 minutes away there's
assumption that some of them may well
travel to site but for people that
aren't living locally and would need to
find accommodation with the Morton
district either through temporary
accommodation or buying a permanent
house they're assuming a much closer
distance of 60 minutes so that they're
hopefully rights on that point I think
in terms of the impact on the
trafficking environment I think you've
councilor swine is correctly identified
that we're very concerned about the lack
of evidence and detail and I think I can
give some reassurances that before an
application is submitted to the
development concerning section
Inspectorate for development consent
order there will need to be that
evidence submitted and there will be a
requirement for a formal environmental
impact assessment to non-it to establish
the baseline against which impacts will
be assessed and that will be a very
robust and and technical exercise so
effectively I agree there that we the
consultation is come a little bit early
to have the real evidence behind it and
hence the the response that we're
recommending is very much asking for
that before we commit herself to any any
view on the specifics of of the the
paragraph I I'm struggling to find that
I think from the reference is that a
reference in the appendix a and and
therefore you know be useful to to to
provide some context
because I think some of some of the
wording might not be significant but
insane there's in principle support I've
just just haven't been able to review
that section so perhaps I could come
back to it later thank you
I have counsel amazed now please
chairman I did ask it to what the impact
would be before council amazed well I'm
sorry I've just got the list okay times
in front of me the mines but yes good
afternoon mr. chairman my question is
actually around the decommissioning of
the development and what the afterlife
is of the decommissioned reactor in 60
years time and how much additional time
on top of that the site will actually
take to decommission so we're not
because we're not just looking at the
building of it and then it's live and
then its afterlife and none of that
seems to have been addressed either in
any of the documents that I've seen and
I'm very concerned about the total
infrastructure that goes alongside this
both before during its commissioning
whilst it is actually a reactor and then
during its decommissioning we just don't
have that deep that infrastructure both
within this district but also in
Chelmsford and obviously going around to
South wooden which is part of chunks of
district as well and I'm very very
concerned about that element of it just
not enough information from for me Thank
You mr. chairman then miss councillors
stamp please Joan I just wants to know
I'm the gentleman and mr. Kingston ass
said about the impacts on the modern
housing market does he have any
statistics for that anything to back
that up is it positive negative but
we're going to be left in ten years that
loads more houses what before I come to
you mr. Kings off again I'll gather to
us
members at a time and perhaps you can
answer their questions at the same time
counselor skeins yes of course
I've grown up with the bread well a with
all the concerns around that but this is
not primarily as nothing compared to
this is the size of it well I'm not
obviously no expert it does seem
unnecessarily large and and and it just
really worries me how big this is and it
seems like it and this and the physical
size 60 meters full building 60 meters I
I just have serious reservations about
the whole thing especially because
rolls-royce only recently announced that
they're going to be having these micro
nuclear power units for a fraction of
the cost
online by 2029 I think we all need to
keep in in our minds that this may not
be necessary and they're also all other
political considerations which I won't
go into here but I just wanted to
express my deep concern about the
massive scale of this project it seems
to me that it doesn't need to be so
massive and so destructive Thank You mr.
Kings no there's several questions or
the last three speakers I think yes
thank you chairman
I think on the first point about the the
if you like legacy post operation I I
think the the consultation does like
detail and it's a part and I think we
need more detail on in terms of the
decommissioning although I do appreciate
that the the planning inspectorate's
and Secretary of State might not require
as much as we like I think this is a
sort of a national issue that members
might be aware that has been looked at
by government in terms of finding a more
sustainable long-term solution for for
nuclear waste but that isn't necessarily
something that
we were consulted on at the moment and
obviously the office of nuclear
Regulation would would have a lot of say
in terms of the safety of such events in
terms of the local housing market the
consultation is is very poor in terms of
details there are no proposals for
permanent housing and any lights
references to potential impacts on the
market on the housing market within
Malden there is a reference to housing
fund that may be support provided by bi
bean in the future to try and address
any negative impacts and as officers we
are we do have concerns that we have a
relatively low amount of private rented
units or just general accommodation
whether that's tourists or otherwise to
accommodate a very large number of
workers so it is very much a concern
that we will be looking to have detailed
discussion with the RV going forward in
terms of the scale of the of the power
station to some extent it is what it is
it is a proposal for a more conventional
nuclear power station and not not not a
one for a micro unit so I think it's
it's something that it's you know we we
have to do with it as as presented to us
it's it's not that we were can say that
we would like something smaller we can
do is try and use this process to
influence what we can so that the design
has much less impact in the landscape
and and it might otherwise but
inevitably about scale it will be highly
prominent and and have a I would say an
adverse impact on the landscape Thank
You councillor nun Thank You chairman
yes in looking at the power station in
the round unconscious of the potential
economic
Vantage's of this development but as
we've heard from the presentation we're
looking at a 60 year legacy when we say
a 60 year legacy even after that
duration it's my view that some of that
legacy will be irreversible so in
looking at the current proposal was at
this current stage there are four issues
that I'd like to raise these German the
first is that some I feel and I'm not
alone here because I've had this raised
by some of my some of the electorate in
my ward that there is a feeling of undue
haste about this both in terms of
members and member involvement and
member consultation but particularly
about public consultation and I'm
concerned that the current knockdown and
the current emergency situation that we
find ourselves in has had a detrimental
impact on meaningful meaningful
consultation that's the first issue the
second issue is that I'm concerned about
the changing economic relationship
across the world as a result of the
current emergency and how that may or
may not impact on our partnerships in
developing Brad will be the third issue
is the impact on infrastructure and when
you look at the changes that have been
proposed to the road system to lorry
parks to car parks to train system these
are irreversible changes and the fourth
and final issue and you won't be
surprised to hear me say mr. chairman is
the impact on our unique environmental
and historical context of the den G
Peninsula and particularly Brad ball
which has an amazing story that starts
during the Roman period and goes right
through as we've heard to the Second
World War so there are four areas of
concern that I wanted to raise this
afternoon thank you
councilís you wanna see a Shaughnessy I
was sorry
apologies as I always say I've started
to say I agree with all the points that
councillors have made so far
and indeed councillor none has gone
before me in talking about this
consultation period which is a huge
concern that it's you know about to stop
in a couple of weeks time potentially
when you know the public haven't had a
proper haven't properly been able to air
their views and I think there should
still be you know eventually when it's
able to happen some group meetings about
this you know in village halls etc as
the attention originally was supposed to
be I think that should go ahead it that
concerns me greatly as it does
councillor none and also just like to
remind everybody I think mr. Dobson
touched on it at the beginning of his
talk that the principle of the need for
nuclear power and the potential for
Bradwell as a site is a matter for
central government and so as such it's
really sort of outside the scope of this
consultation so all the details laid out
today are somewhat irrelevant at the
moment and may lead people to think that
it is a done deal which of course it is
not the the it will be up to central
government whether this goes ahead or
not so I think we are in danger of
giving local people the wrong impression
here thank you
and could I just add that Chelmsford
City Council have also made a report on
this and nobody's mentioned it yet
Thank You chairman Thank You councillor
Shaughnessy um councillor siddle Thank
You chairman
I just like to back up what some of the
other councillors have said one of the
things that the Conservative government
is very keen on doing now is to ensure
that road improvements and
infrastructure are done before any kind
of construction like this so I believe
that we need to push for that and ensure
that we get that infrastructure before
any speed up or in the ground one of the
things that's been in the press recently
is about the the potential new train a
line that's linking moulton to Witham my
view is if we are going to have Park and
Ride as part of this proposal we should
try and look at ensuring that Park &
Ride is developed within Molden so we
can then run a shuttle bus service and
use that facility to the train station
at Hatfield petrol or Twitter so we are
immediately getting your benefits to
this again I'm with counts on the skenes
this is outdated technology rolls-royce
have been announcing these small nuclear
plants we need to ensure that we get the
message across that hopefully the
government will review some of this and
come up with the right proposals what
I'd also like to do is to thank Georgina
button and her team for all the great
work that they've done in producing
these documents and producing these
reports thank you Thank You mr. Kings
North miss batten do you want to comment
on the last few speakers at all yeah
just go first and respond to the
question and in relation to how the
consultation has been carried out
rightly so you had this
concerns as we did and we pointed it out
when the corona virus pandemic started
and went to beyond being said you know
how are you going to respond to this are
you going to stop the consultation pick
it up at a more suitable time how are
you going to make sure that it is
accessible bearing in mind we signed off
the accounts or supported the statement
of community consultation which set out
their approach in how they were going to
consult with the public now because of
the pandemic their response was that
they extended the consultation from 12
weeks to 17 weeks and what they've done
is adapt the their offering so there's
obviously the telephone surgeries which
I know you know some people have had
some good experiences and bad
experiences with that and there's also
the online materials on the website and
other email and printed materials
newsletters and so on that they have
produced now when we've questioned it
and said well actually you know is that
enough is that right
they have come back to say that the
National infrastructure planning
Association have come back and said that
they recognize their efforts as positive
examples of responding to the pandemic
and also what I did was question well
how many responses have they had thus
far and how does that compare to the
other consultations that they've carried
out and they said you know it's just
there less than a week to go they've had
over a thousand people and organizations
of seeing and including some of the ones
who talked about already provided for
more feedback to the consultation
through the multiple channels that
they've got now comparing that to over
in angle C or Hinkley Point C in
Somerset or indeed sighs well we were at
this stage at 424 feedback feedback
responses Hinkley Point C had 700 and
more side in West Cambria at 750 and
sighs well 1300 now they all all
consultations always see a spike in the
last week they're pushing that through
radio advertisement which they've never
done before to try and promote that
there is
it's your time to respond and they have
promised us that they will in before
they proceed to stage to look at the
results of the consultation to see if
they need to indeed do that again or do
something differently I think the other
issue here as well is it's just pointing
out at this very early stages it is a
non-statutory consultation so there
isn't really anybody expecting this
consultation to be carried out in a
formal way so they are able to come back
and say we have willingly consulted
we've provided multiple channels in
which people can engage unfortunately
yes there was a pandemic but we did
still receive a significant or a
comparable number of responses so
whether if we like that or not I think
you know I think it's they've got
justification there and they are happy
with how they have conducted it thus far
what we have done jointly with Essex
County Council is submitted a letter to
the chief executive on the 23rd of April
making it clear that we had those
concerns and that we felt that that did
that needs to be reflected in a
statement of community consultation now
that letter will also be seen by the
Inspectorate at the point of examination
that we've found out we can't do that
now but they will look at those concerns
that we raised at this stage at the
point of concert at the point of
examination thank you miss button mr.
Kings nose did you want to add anything
or can I go on I'll still got several
members wish to speak and thank you
chairman I think just to come back on a
few points that be made by our
councillors
I think county councillor settles
comments that you'll be better if the
road improvements be done before
construction sites construction begins I
think that Danny's eminently sensible
but I think the technical studies will
have to conclude whether or not there
would be you know significant harm to
stop them starting so I think that's
that's something that I I agree with the
sentiment
it's just it'll come down to the
technical appraisals to see what what
harms caused in terms of those those
traffic flows which we do not know at
the moment also in terms of councilor
none mentioning the infrastructure and
irreversible changes I think they're I
would comment that much of the
infrastructure like the freight
management centers and park-and-ride
sites may well be temporary
infrastructure so what what we as the
council need to do is make sure that the
infrastructure that's permanent is
either positive legacy for the district
and not a negative one I think I share
counselor nuns view that it's we have a
unique environment and therefore you
know we thought that we will be doing
their best to ensure that that
uniqueness remains intact
I think elsa Banford thank you chair and
firstly i just wanted to thank gathering
for the presentation which was excellent
and very informative and for all the
hard work that the other offices have
done I was on the Bridewell working
group it was my one my first virtual
meetings and and I felt I didn't really
put all my points across their emphasis
the emphasis was mainly on
transportation so I just really want to
ask the officers now to reassure me that
a lot of the concerns and views are
addressed in this response I know that
you are Gavin has said negative
responses of trying to be avoided and
you don't really put wonderful views
across but it is the concerns that that
I want to make sure are addressed in
some way because I live in Tori which is
directly opposite this site and this
will be a massive blot on the landscape
you know we have essex wildlife site we
have an RSPB site we have a glorious sea
wall which will overlook this so I'm
concerned about the visual
impact of this I realize you know there
they are constructing something to meet
a certain need but does it really really
have to be this large because it is
going to be seen for a massive distance
away the hills in great practice isn't
it we're going to see this as they come
in to the area so my other concerns are
the accommodation site as well what what
sort of impact that's going to have on
the on the visual and sight from toes
beside the impact on residential boating
the marine ecology and the oyster beds I
know you've mentioned the cooling towers
have been done on the basis of taking
into consideration ecology but because
of that we've got to look at a massive
massive well to do massive structures so
these are concerns that I want to make
sure our put across in some way and not
just you saying well we haven't got the
details so we can't make any comments so
and the Heritage Sites is another thing
a lot of the Heritage Sites are going to
be badly affected by this so I'm
concerned about that too
also what's happened with the DPD
planning document and are we in our
second response going to have to do a
joint response with ECC or can we
actually ask to do stage two response on
our own thank you very much chairman
Thank You councillor laggin the previous
comments that members have made which I
totally agree most of them but there's
just a couple of points that I wanted to
raise formally on page 26 three point
three on plan
policy 3.35 and Paul at the beginning
said it's a consultation process which I
get I know it's a decision for national
policies not for local policy to be made
and we are only been consulted on this
rather whole program but I am concerned
that back in 2017 the council will
strongly support the principle of
development of the power station of Brad
well that was based in 2017 based on
outdated figures and information about
electricity uses which has since
declined so I know this councillor
certainly doesn't as an independent
person support in principle anything to
be done on the dingy Peninsula the
second point I'd like to raise is where
these on point six of the report
implications where we talk about impact
on customers it says it could have
significant benefits and impacts and
more than residents and businesses I
think it was raised earlier on I think
by councillor Siddal that the
recommendation is to debate today to
accept the rail officers recommendations
well I find it a little bit
short-sighted that the impact on
customers could have significant
benefits without massive destruction and
over development and loss of what we
actually have a which my previous
members have mentioned and having worked
on massive construction sites across the
world with my own eyes seeing the
destruction that it causes so I have I
have great great reservations in
supporting a lot of water in here
although home also appreciative of the
detail that the officers have gone to
especially Tim has all these marvelous
as always document on the heritage down
there it's the most important decision
I've ever had the opportunity to
contribute to and I don't want us to get
it wrong by selling the silver too early
because once we once we move on this
everything for the infrastructure to the
impact of migrant workers really won't
we won't understand anything like this
in our in our time so I'm very much
against standing for it in a positive
way
Thank You mid-tier going I've got two
more speakers I think Tara unless you've
got some more councillor Fleming and
then councillor Morris councillor
Fleming
Thank You chair uh my question was for
mr. Kings North I wanted to ask him you
know how much detail he he looked into
transferred City Council's plans for new
housing around Southwood in Ferris when
he was you know preparing the
consultation that's my concern that's an
awful lot of housing going in around
South with him
the roads are insufficient president I
just yeah wanted to find out how much
detail he needs looked into Thank You
councillor Morris I think you're the
final speaker then I've I've got a
notice of a recorded vote required which
is okay sorry and I throw it wait a
minute let me finish and a notice of an
amendment to remove some words which
will take when I go back to the leader
councillor Morris I was going to request
a recorded vote
so thank you for that councillor Langan
is pretty much covered what I was going
to say but I'll make it short and sweet
it's dangerous it's dirty and it's all
full as cancelling and said page 26
3.3.5 the council who strongly support
the principle of the development of a
new nuclear power station at Breville
and see that there isn't anything that I
want to be involved with I don't support
this one bit we shouldn't be doing it
thank you
nobody don't predetermination in there
then and now now you'll be doing it
should we it's not prepared overnight
mr. Kings Dolf do you want to come back
with any on anything the last few
speakers have said before I return to
mr. before I returned to councilor
cloaca
and chairman yes if I just pick up on a
few few of these sort of questions from
councillors in terms if I take me
reverse order councillor Fleming said to
what extent are we aware of or taken
into account the proposals around
Southport and ferries within the chumps
at City Council area I can reassure
councillor Fleming that I've I've been
involved in in many discussions with
chamfered City Council I'm and fully
aware of their their consultation
response at their meeting on the 6th of
June also with Essex County Council
highways we've been looking into the
background to South Oldham ferry's
expansion and so that development is
very much been part of our minds and and
recognizing that there's constraints
beyond the modern district that will
need to be addressed in terms of Council
and I think my main comment is that
there will be benefits but there also be
disadvantages or impacts that would have
on the council so it's not it is just
one of those planning things where we
need to balance the positives are going
to the negatives and come to a balanced
view and that's also the task of the
planning inspector and the Secretary of
State when it gets to to them in terms
of the council's position it is only an
in-principle support
so therefore this this stage gives us
the object opportunities it's
particularly at stage two and beyond to
consider the details and then come to a
view as to the balance of planning
merits at that point in terms of
councillor Bamford's comments I
certainly can reassure councillor
Manfred that all of the areas that have
been raised will be taking into account
and we will have detailed discussions
with Brad will be our be in in future to
cover all of those areas they are quite
valid and legitimate concerns that we
will be addressing in due course and
just as a final comment I've been
searching for councillor Swain's
proposed amendment but the record of the
paragraph I took even referring to
parent appendix I haven't been out to
find it so perhaps we can I think I
think I think
miss Byrd has got that in pain thank you
I think I do have one more speaker which
I seem to have missed and that's
councillor Thompson Thompson I just
wanted to say I heartily agree with
pretty much everything everyone said and
concern for the district and the
environment and the heritage and
everything but you know can we please
remember we all we can't decide whether
this is gonna happen or not that's out
of our hands we can only make sure we
get the best out of it we possibly can
at the district and I'd like to thank
all the offices and everyone who's
worked on this report I think they've
done an excellent job covered an awful
lot I I would ask everyone to endorse it
I think we should have a joint response
with County if possible I do have one
question if I could ask through you
chairman if we make any amendments to
this does that stop it being a joint
response with Essex thank you yeah
that's a good question perhaps we will
pick that up later there are as I said
Tom Tara have you got that councillor
Swain amendment I think you did indicate
on chat to me at one stage that you
showed it to me was I incorrect chairman
say something I can't use chats
right where's this bit I think he's
talking about this paragraph Gemma three
point five point five
councilman Swain is that the paragraph
you're referring to yes and this has
been in the officer's report chairman
just to advise and your yes you can't
actually make amendments to this because
it's the officers report
perhaps the leader can pick up on this
and well I can't you can't vote you
can't vote on this but perhaps the
leader will be cognition of it and take
it up you can wear chairman say what I
wanted to what I wanted to do it's it's
um and they don't we found a councillor
Thompson's point this really only
affects Malden because that paragraph
refers to the Malden Council the council
singular and it obviously refers to
Morton's District my proposal was there
to read the consultation response and
welcomes the outcomes detailed
discussion across a wide range of topics
and to take out the meant they face
confirms the council's in principal
councillors I think councillor Swain
schemes we cannot change by amendment
officers reports okay y'all have to
speak to the leader who will be aware of
what you are proposing and I will leave
it to him to come up with either a
suggestion or a rejection chairman that
we've already mentioned what's in the
LDP so it seems quite unnecessary to
make a repeat in 3 / 5 thank you yeah
but we can't touch that as members can
against it
yes I'm indeed so chairman I think just
just for clarity can we just talk an you
please put the put this part of the
report back on the screen so that I can
understand from councillor Swain what he
wants to do because I might be able to
appease them and everybody else probably
so it's three point five point five hm
through you could I ask
displaying what he wants to do we move
the words the counseling principal
support yes and it's fairly to follow
the consultation response welcomes
detailed discussion etc and leaves out
the wedding before that one between so
it leaves out confirms counsels in
principle support for the development
and write the simplest way out of this
mr. Kings North would you like to remove
those words or is there a basic
principle here chairman if I can
intercede I don't think we can because
counsel had previously voted and that
was the stance of counsel at the time
yes you're quite right but surely this
is it we now now got more detail
material differences it were leader I'll
hand it back to you and I won't try and
solve this conundrum well chairman III
can certainly understand
I can certainly up I can certainly
understand where counselor Suede's come
from and indeed council Erskine is
concerned about this and quietly too
because these these comments were picked
up in a previous administration which of
course they weren't on the council then
so we are you know we are saddled with
the local development plan from there's
a job to 2017 the report actually says
2107 but anyway so two seven two
thousand team adopted the local
development plan so you know we're three
and a half years into that or whatever
and and it's quite right
this statement that appears at three
point three point five is contained
within that report but of course we we
are do a review I think we're going to
start the review of the local
development plan which we require to by
law I think probably next year probably
the spring of next year be about a
12-month process and and I think it's at
that time that we need to go to the
members and understand what their mood
is in relation to the
use comments around the nuclear power
station but we have to wait until then
because we can Saddam is quite right
it's a decision account so it's been
endorsed by Council so we need to
unlevel that there but chairman
and I think that's the right and proper
place to do this but you know I've
listened very carefully to what a lot of
members have said about this and of
course the great opportunity for us to
respond is easily the statutory
consultation which is the next
consultation and if you can remember
quite some time ago I proposed another
recommendation so tower can you put the
recommendation up I sent it to you by
email can you pop that up on the screen
that's that that's the grandmas you're
the niece and nephew right okay so that
members are regularly consulted with
from the start of the DCO stage to
statutory consultation process right so
that means when the stage two comes
along you know you'll have your working
groups you'll have your member
interaction it can go to strategy and
resources so that we get total
involvement from day one because in my
mother we haven't quite got that right
because we've been pushed so quickly on
this so I think that's very important
and I hope members will support that but
chairman I'd add I'd also propose that
we review the council's position when we
review the local development plan when
we do the statue to review the local
development plan we actually review the
decision regarding Bret will be I don't
know if any want to be brave enough to
second that but I think that would
certainly mean that we can look at it
but Appleby would understand that we're
going to review it and then we can take
it forward from there Jim but other than
that I would ask that you put the the
two recommendations as their ear on the
order paper and also my two new
recommendations chairman regarding
member involvement and a review of the
statements regarding the power station
when we get to the local government plan
would you make that the fourth one
please
so members can steer up
I mean chairman in some way it's very
very important that you know when we get
to the statutory response we've booked
get all the views of the members and we
make sure that this is you know this is
reiterated through that process I think
chairman because of the the enormity of
this piece of work and the way if
somebody's quite rightly say to you know
it stretches across the outside of our
district
we've got highways involved we've got
other things involved you know I think
we should work very very closely with
Essex County Council but if members are
really really really unhappy I mean we
could add a recommendation on that that
we we consider that part of the
commencement of the stage to DCO
statutory consultation but I'm trying to
make this as easy as possible for
members because we could of course visit
that later on anyway council I think I
meant as the easiest possible debate
again councillors wine and schemes that
fourth one that the leaders suggesting
would that satisfy you in part and yes
given that he can't actually as we say
amend reporter such then it probably as
as satisfactory the solution as we can
get yeah put me recommendations all four
of those two to the council will you
start calling the roll please can I just
clarify recommendation for and I think
it it might be policy but I think
somebody cleverer than me she'd answer
that perhaps that means at least the
other thirty members I'm not sure I'm
not sure hospitality all its play cause
there is there somebody there how's your
position sounds yeah
right there we go so let's get that
quickly in counsels position when hello
Ellen plan is reviewed so okay
chairman okay Tara thank you for that
will you now call the roll again it's
for the recommendations against or
abstain yes chairman of course and
members I will call automatically start
some accounts of Bamford please sorry
time trying to get this sorry I just
want to raise something which I did ask
in the chair in the appendix a at number
two it does say that the council support
in principle yes I think that's what
we've done we've been through in the
actual appendix chairman that that is
why the leader has suggested the
recommendation for and counselor swine
has accepted it all right so can we move
on Tara please
yes Jenna so it counts the bouncer for
Thank You Casa passenger against mr.
Bell again thank you that's a voice
saying Casa tua caps the Durham for
Thank You Chancellor Edwards against
Fleming for
[Music]
Sarika thought let's let the meeting
capsule heard for council home or can
you cancel Jarvis for Enki Casa keys or
canceled again against that's amaze
against malli for as amorous definitely
against you cancel none against against
that's the Siddle for cancer skiing's
against that's the step against stilts
against rain against mrs. Thompson for
council miss white has left 14 for 12
against and one affection and thank you
that is therefore carried and we will
then move on to agenda item 11 approval
to adopt a list of local heritage assets
forever on see and telling them before
you move on could you just give us a
couple of this is China back please
sorry yeah that's fine just bear with us
thank you
cool don't forget your pitch she'll go
mad
which is contacting her chairman I'm
just waiting for her to rejoin won't
keep you long
thank you turn your video of Councillors
wine please
have we got mrs. Jenner bank with us
Tara yes Cassie Boyce we had mrs. Chan
with us thank you thank you here
agenda item 11 approval to adopt the
list of local heritage assets for Brad
Berlin see until IAM found on pages one
nine one two two four four and I will
call on the leader of the council to
present this item or remind you about
the chat function
I will then come to you in turn
following the leader of the council's
presentation and I know we've got mr.
house and with us to give a report but
leader I can't hear the leader chairman
there we go thank you very much so just
to recap we're on page one nine one and
we're on agenda item 11 which is the
approval of the list of local heritage
assets for Brad will and telling them
about the poignant bear in mind what
we've just discussed I think we're well
rehearsed it was saving these documents
but we hearse again to say just as much
warmth as I did the first time and and
that was to pay tribute to mr. housen
who I think it's very much a one-man
team at the moment so well done to him
for a fabulous we pull and the detail
and actually keeping track of all these
wonderful heritage assets that are in
the district so chairman I'm sure other
people who want to add to that but I
think the brevity being a man that at
the time chairman I'll give way to mr.
house and if that's where you're going
and then I'll come back to the
recommendation thank you yes I can hear
you loud and clear
can you see my screen yes
yes I've just got a five minute
presentation on the Brad well and
telling them they call lists so as you
all know these are lists of historic
buildings which fall short of the strict
criteria for national listing but
possess local heritage value meriting
some consideration empowering decisions
and preparation of these lists is
something encouraged in planning
practice guidance the draft lift lists
for Bradwell and Tillingham were
approved for public consultation by
strategy and resources committee on the
22 february 20 20 and the documents
simply identify and celebrate a really
interesting collection of historic
buildings i'm going to briefly show you
a few of the highlights in chronological
order the oldest of which is the King's
Head Inn Brad Whelan see which has a
recently restored late medieval
timber-framed cross wing on the
left-hand side of the building this
ancient structure was revealed by a fire
in 2014 and was accurately restored
following the evidence in the Timbers
this is a view of the interior shortly
after the fire and as it looks now
faithfully restored and this is an
isometric reconstruction showing the
structure of the building and the
original medieval Timbers in brown and
the new oak structure replicating the
original in green quite a remarkable
survival that would be statutory listed
if more of it survived the fire several
of the entries on the lists fall into
the category of small Georgian cottages
of which tile cottage in Tillingham is a
fine example this was built in 1812 on a
slip of roadside waste it's a relatively
unusual survival of a detached cottage
which was originally just one room on
the ground floor on one room in the
Attic normally cottages this small we're
in terraced form it has a clay tile
Gambel roof which is such a
characteristic feature of George and
vernacular buildings in the coastal
region of Essex on the right is an early
20th century photograph illustrating one
of the past occupants
Weymouth none mall was a fisherman wild
Fowler and longshoreman all occupations
relating to the marshland location and
where possible the lists have included
old photographs like this most of which
have been kindly provided by the local
historian Kevin Bruce who you may know
as a former district councillor later in
the 19th century the lord of the manor
of Tillingham the Dean and chapter of
sand pools erected several pairs of
cottages with these distinctive Sussex
tile tile hung dormer windows the best
reserve examples of these houses such as
numbers 1 2 3 Brook Road have been
included on the Tillingham list and
these cottages were designed by the
notable County Architect Frederick
Chancellor and this is a little sketch
he prepared in 1881 when the cottages
were originally proposed and then among
the youngest buildings to be included on
the Bradwell list are those from World
War 2 this was a significant period in
Brad Wells history which saw the whole
parish become a military zone and some
significant wartime structures are still
standing on what was Brad well Bay
airfield including the control tower
which was converted to a house after the
wall now these buildings are likely to
be demolished at the nuclear power
station is built but I think at least
inclusion on the local list at least
highlights the importance of these
military buildings and if they do have
to go they should be properly recorded
in total three representations were
received during the local list public
consultation and the owners of Gate
House in Brad Wells submitted the only
objection they objected to the inclusion
of their their house this was built in
1836 as a lodge at the entrance to the
grounds of the rectory and it is
unfortunately not that well preserved
its windows and modern the chimney has
very recently been demolished and the
owners are actually about to implement a
planning permission to alter the form of
the roof so taking all that into account
the building is now considered
insufficiently well-preserved to meet
the selection criteria and so has been
omitted from the draft list a dwell on C
parish council suggested several other
buildings for inclusion and most of
which unfortunately fell short of the
selection criteria some of them were
already great you listed
however they their proposal to include
the group of pillboxes along the seawall
has been incorporated and because while
individually the pillboxes are perhaps
not that remarkable as a group they are
quite a potent visible reminder of the
real threat of invasion posed during
World War two and so the local list for
Bradwell RC has been amended to include
these pillboxes as a single entry and so
the recommendation is to adopt the lists
and that will support the council's
strategic thing for place by encouraging
the protection and improvement of built
heritage which is a valuable component
of the local environment Thank You mr.
housen many years ago the council
produced a leaflet on all the fill boxes
around Babel and it Cook was called the
pillbox walk as we enter the different
designs of bill boxes right now I have
counseled none wishes to speak yes thank
you very much chairman could I thank mr.
Houston for an excellent piece of work
and indeed an excellent overall
initiative
I've seen his versions of these papers
for modern Highbridge and South Minster
and this this addition is very much
welcomed these sites and buildings as
he's quite rightly pointed out are not
currently recognized on a statutory
basis they're not listed so it's really
important that we do record these
features of our district and I think
what they do particularly this report is
that they highlight the absolute
sensitivity historical built history
sensitivity of Brad wall not leads the
control tower or more correctly watch
tower from re f Brad will buy and I very
much hope as one that the watch tower
survives but I'd like to thank mr.
Hansen for an excellent piece of work
Council of Lucca yeah thank you cannot
turn but still particularly on this type
of matter I'll always give away to
Council that none but chairman are
obviously living out here most of my
life and I've known the the watch towers
it's cold or whatever it is and but
chairman I once asked mr. house bear in
mind what we've just dealt with with
Brad will be whether or not there is
anything we can do to bring weight on
web will be to at least try and preserve
the control tower I call it because
everyone calls it the control tower or
and and just a little bit of clarity at
one stage I thought the blister
buildings were involved in this they
were involved in this list as well which
are up on the airfield and and I you
know I I can't help thinking I know I
know counts the schemes he's quite keen
on the old control tower as well but I
can't help thinking you know if it is
right in the middle of their
construction area then you know maybe
these people should be asked to to move
it somewhere else on the site so that it
could be preserved to its full glory but
I just wondered what what mr. Hale
stands for long was that and I suppose I
should also say cuz I always do that
Papa did fly a couple of times in a
mosquito during the war but you didn't
know his hands on the controls to be
honest so thank you chairman councilor
stamp Thank You chairman I just want to
say thank you also to mr. Hansen and
when are you doing Burnham's I have
asked that before but we all seen to it
bottom the pal and but also I'd like to
say how important it is and how
disappointed I am that I understand that
it's from central government that we as
a council seem to be supporting the Brad
well be when we're going to lose half of
what's going to be on that screen oh
maybe not losing it it's going to be in
- donít isn't it and I think it's an
absolute shame that we've got such
fantastic heritage and coastline that is
going to change forever and some
people's views it's going to be ruined
chairman and I understand in other
people's views it's not in my personal
view which I don't normally say unless
they have to
I'm really sad that we're gonna have to
have that there if we do I am hoping
that modern technology is going to make
sure it's moved somewhere else because
it isn't just going to have an impact on
bread well it's having an impact on the
Malden district per se and I think the
District Council should have fought
harder to try and stop this coming here
thank you thank you mr. house and a
lovely bit of work again mr. Houston
you're doing well but you're still
presenting your slides and I think Oh am
I stop sharing is that better
that's it thank you counselor mrs.
channa Thank You chairman well I think
some members have said actually what I
was going to be saying I would just like
to thank mr. Houston because obviously
I'm no longer chair of P&L we've changed
that committee structure but I'm a very
much aware of his commitment and
dedication and the amount of work he
does actually in reports like this and
what he pulls together relax adding
local heritage assets and I think it's a
testament to this district and I think
it's a testament to his work and what he
does he's actually helped put Malden on
the map and I very much hope that as a
council we do help to preserve some of
this heritage that we've been left with
but also for future generations because
it would be a shame to see it all go
thank you um Kelso Dom I've got your
name down but I'm not sure did you wish
to speak Javanese left for meeting their
cancer dome all right okay I'm sorry is
there anybody I've missed a cassen
Morley was wishing to speak chairman
Thank You councillor moley councillor
Morley you with us on mute
and you hear me yes yes
Thank You chairman I'm just really
reiterating what councillor Nunn was
saying I'm most concerned about the
watchtower and if it is any way it can
be rebuilt in somewhere else or somehow
preserved thank you very much
Thank You mr. housen as has been said by
others you've done a brilliant job you
do a brilliant job for promoting and our
district and thank you very much I'll
now go to the leader to sum up before I
put this motion to the vote yeah thank
you very much chairman and I think that
it goes without saying all about thanks
to mr. house and maybe we should just
note that when we agree the
recommendation in the moment that we
extend our thanks for this great piece
of work but generally the recommendation
is straightforward and I think it leaves
open the way if we can try and work with
these people if the power station does
come forward that we do try and preserve
the watchtower and the blister buildings
that way marks they are in the list they
are important and you know this is a
mass a massive infrastructure project we
know there's huge amounts of money
involved and you know I'd like to think
that they would respect our local
heritage assets and work with us to try
and preserve them either where they are
or on the edge of the site so till now
I've said that but it quite simply
Chairman I I would propose that we agree
the recommendation with a note of thanks
to mr. house and fall of his work thank
you
call the roll please questions the
leader of the council any members got a
question will they please speak now or
be quiet because we've been out at three
hours now any questions on but 101
come on then okay so I've noticed that
we have a rainbow flag up outside our
council offices is that clear
doesn't that that that signifies our
recognition and support of the LGBT
community and in fact I've been involved
in the raising of that flag in the past
and nothing gives me more pleasure than
seeing it flying over the council
offices and we've been flying a lot of
flags in recognition of all sorts of
different diverse groups and I'm glad
you're aware of it and it is something
that gets my 100 percent support Thank
You chairman right and what I would like
to say homophobic comments by anyone any
councillors such as one that was made
recently just a couple of days ago by
councillor Wyatt well at be tackled
robustly well I all I can say to you is
is that you know if anybody wants to
make complaint against another council
so they should do that and that is
something that I would always support so
if any if any councillor has a problem
they should make a complaint and and and
speak to and speak to the monitoring
office and can I just say that
councillor Mays is in fact she's got a
rainbow up now and it's something that I
called with and I stand by those and
marks are just said thank you Jim all
right thank you any other member have
this question right thank you will then
move on to agenda item business
14 business by reason of special
circumstances considered by a chairman
I've got a face of someone who's called
Robin a guest on my computer yeah that's
I think sorry chairman and and I think
that's somebody who's coming in for the
next item sighted interrupt
I think it's what Ben Thompson I think
but anyway apologies chairman just to
move things for you right turn right and
40 realize I had no additional urgent
business
we move to agenda item 15 and I shall
read the motion of exclusion of the
public and press we are now we now move
into private session and I move that
under Section 104 of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public and press
be excluded from the meeting during
consideration of the following item of
business on the grounds that it involves
the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 3
part 1 of schedule 12a to the act and
this satisfies of public interest it
tests seconded and that's in relation to
leisure contracts thank you is that is
that agreed yes yes we need to switch
off the public phase now faces members
of the public
yeah chairman would just get
confirmation that's turned off